we glad that you could join us for this
Q&A and my name is uh Pastor Enoch BOGO
and with me is Pastor Randy we're glad
you're here thank you and if you would
kindly open for us with a word of prayer
yes indeed let's pray our loving father
in Heaven we're so grateful to you for
the gift of life and for the honor of
speaking for you cleanse us from all
unlikeness all that is unlike you I pray
and Grant to us the words of wisdom that
those listening might be led into a
closer relationship with you bless
everyone listening and every country
represented by those listening I pray in
Jesus name amen amen and amen thank you
very much welcome we will take our first
question which is how does one conquer
appetite appetite was the problem Adam
had and Eve the first Adam fell on the
point of appetite the second Adam
conquered on the point of appetite and
this is not actually accidental the
devil knows that through an an inability
to control appetite he really has access
to someone to control that person
appetite is conquered by delivering up
the will to God and the will is that
place where we make decisions yes no
I'll do this I won't do that this must
be yielded to God constantly the
surrender must be daily when that
happens God works in us to control this
tremendous urge called appetite and they
are two very power powerful urges the
desire for food the desire for sexual uh
interaction and both are connected to
survival food I Stay Alive by food
sexual activity produce children the
race is preserved and they are very
strong urges put in Us by God but God
also gave us a mind a will which is
designed to control because the appetite
has no mind of its own the appetite is
not a thinking organism it is just a
power that must be controlled it is
controlled by the will placed into the
Hands of Christ when that is done it is
Christ that exercises the power through
us to control those urges which we call
animal passions there's nothing wrong
with them but they must be controlled as
I said by a will surrendered to the
power of Jesus Christ as the Bible says
God works in us to willing to do
according to his good pleasure uh so I
strongly urge anyone with a struggle
with appetite it's not an easy struggle
and God understand answer daily
surrender of the will to him and also
keep in mind your body is the Temple of
the Holy Ghost the Holy Spirit and we
must glorify God in our body and in our
spirit and so when you abuse this body
by ere eating you're abusing something
that literally belongs to God it does
not belong to you this is literal
language not symbolic and so I urge you
surrender your will to God entirely not
99% 100 do it daily perhaps more than
daily it doesn't take long to say father
I Surrender my will to you guide and
direct me and through that process and
by your own effort the key is divine
power and human effort and the Victory
will eventually be yours amen so what
Pastor you saying is I come to God and I
ask him I desire to do your will please
give me the strength to live by it and
you make an you make an effort make an
effort yes yes you cooperate with God
that is exactly the case amen number two
is what is the right way to Fast And if
someone uh feels hungry and they are
tempted they end up eating in the middle
of their period of fasting is this a sin
all right fasting essentially is a
voluntary Act of self-denial you're
denying yourself something you really
really love and need usually people fast
from food because food is what keeps Us
Alive you see and so we fast from it we
deny ourselves that self-denial is a
central tenant of a relationship with
Christ Christ's entire life was one of
self-denial now why do I say that let's
reason in the scriptures in John 8:29
Jesus said and he that have sent me is
with me the father hath not left me
alone for I do always those things that
please him this is self denial I doing
what he wants not what I want we know
that Jesus wanted to do some things of
his own own will because he said in the
Garden of Gethsemane father if thou be
willing remove this cup from me
nevertheless not my will but thine be
done Christ's entire life was one of he
fasted from self if I may put it that
way his ultimate actions were all
connected to is this the will of God and
so fasting as I said is voluntary
self-denial you may fast from food you
may fast from social media you may fast
from television you may fast from
whatever that may be injuring you never
fast from something that is good you
fast as a spiritual principle to develop
to grow a spiritual exercise if in
fasting you fall and you
eat I won't classify that a sin unless
you had made a promise to God if you
said father for the next nine hours I
will not eat I promise you I will now
you do that and then you eat you sinned
but if you let me try to fast for 9
hours and you eat you have not sinned
yes you did not keep your word but you
did not make a promise to God but if you
keep trying you will come to the place
where you honor your desires to fast and
as I said earlier it can be from food
television overeating whatever uh sweets
time with your girlfriend your boyfriend
you know whatever going to soccer
watching Arsenal and Manchester United
all of that we can fast from if you're
new to fasting and you want to fast fast
from food take it
slowly don't go fasting for 3 days and
you've never fasted before God is not an
unreasonable God he calls us to reason
Isaiah 118 fast for the morning meal or
fast from the afternoon work yourself
into it slowly then you may consider an
entire day or two days or 3 days but
ultimately the purpose is spiritual
growth spiritual power Jesus said about
some demons they're not cast out except
by prayer and fasting fasting is an
absolutely essential spiritual exercise
thank you we'll take the next one and uh
the question says will the 144 be part
of those who go through the time of
trouble or does this number repres is is
this number um uh let me come again is
the
1,00 144,000
uh part of those who go through the
Great Tribulation or does this number
represent the great multitude okay
there's the great multitude in
Revelation 7:9 and there's 144,000 they
br down by tribes Revelation 5 75 to8 so
two different groups there are some
Scholars who think they're the same
group but the Bible gives evidence
they're two different groups when God
called Abraham in Genesis 17 and gave
him circumcision he said he shall keep
my Covenant there therefore then he said
every Manchild among you shall be
circumcised he that is born in the house
or bought with money of any stranger
which is not of thy seed in other words
there's the group biologically attached
to Abraham then there Those whom he
bought in those days people bought
slaves so there were two groups but what
United them was all had to be
circumcised and so we have two groups
the tribes directly from Abraham then we
have the larger multitude the Gentiles
who came into the faith but both saved
by the same sacrifice of Jesus Christ
Christ and
[Music]
so we the
144,000 represent those who will be
alive on the
earth before Christ comes in in
Revelation 6 the last verse says for the
great day of his wrath is come and who
shall be able to stand I that's verse 17
Revelation 6 now in chapter 7 we have
those who will be able to stand we have
the 144,000 but we also have a great
multitude but the 144,000 represent
those who will be alive on the Earth
when the earth goes through the time of
trouble and they will endure a time of
trouble that the world has never seen as
we were warned in Daniel 12:1 whether
it's literal 144,000 or symbolic the
church has no fixed position some
scholars believe it is literal number
other scholars believe it refers to the
quality of the character you know 12 X2
144 it is the the the well-rounded
character the symmetrical character of
Christ represented in those who live
during those very very trying times but
either way the 144,000 are not the only
ones who will be saved we have the large
multitude which no man can
number thank
you what is the difference between faith
and
presumption faith is acting upon the
word of God presumption is acting upon
what you think is right a classic
example when God parted the Red Sea he
told the Israelites to
cross they crossed and they were safe he
did not tell the Egyptians to cross they
tried to cross they were all destroyed
we have two groups one acting by faith
one acting by presumption God called the
Israelites to cross they crossed
everyone was safe when the Egyptians
started Crossing when the entire Army
was in the midst of that Gap then all
the waters came back one act based on
faith one act based on presumption and
you cannot have faith without the word
of God faith is acting upon thus sayith
the Lord it isn't just feeling something
it is trusting God to do what he says
faith isn't expecting God to do what you
say faith is asking God to do what he
says are you following me some people
think faith is God will do what I he
saying no no no faith is God will do
what he says you believe that because
God cannot lie presumption is acting
upon your own impulses your own feelings
your own desires and trying to make them
the will of God there's a fine line that
I'd like to maybe us discuss a little
further on that the devil took Jesus on
top of the mountain he took him on on
the Pinnacle of the temp temp told him
it is written his angels will take
charge of you so how does one
differentiate is this me acting on what
God has said or is this me leading
myself into temptation all right the
devil did say it is written he shall
give his CHS charge over thee they shall
bear the up in their hands he's quoting
from um Psalm 91 verse 11 what he left
out is he shall give his angels charge
over thee to keep thee in all thy ways
he left that out you see because the
devil does not want you or me or you in
the ways of God so he used the scripture
deceptively so if Jesus had jumped in
his
Humanity he would have had two broken
legs a broken hip a dislocated spine
because he would have acted
presumptuously but Jesus said Thou shalt
not tempt the Lord thy God don't do
something you know to be wrong and hope
God will get you out of trouble don't do
that act upon thus sayith the
Lord thank you it must be what God has
asked you to do and it must be in his
line of duty yes and you discover that
as you study the word constantly a lot
of us we want to know God's will only
when a crisis arises but it's by
constantly living in the word of God we
develop the ability to recognize this is
the voice of God or this is not the
voice of God Jesus said my sheep know my
voice you see because they're always
listening to it this is the voice of God
we develop the ability to recognize
God's voice Voice by constantly studying
his word and obeying it you leave out
the obedience you will never recognize
the voice of God thank
you we have a next one which is who was
madc melkisedek was a literal human
being a priest in the days of Abraham in
Genesis 14 we can go there if you like
uh chapter 14 in that chapter lot has
been conquered by some armies that came
over from the other side of euph his
River and they took lot his possessions
all the people and they departed Abraham
was told of what happened and he chased
after them he defeated them brought back
lot the women the children lost
possessions everything in verse 18 says
and melkisedek king of Salem brought
forth Bread and Wine he was the priest
of the most high God so we're introduced
to melkisedek a real person who was the
king of Salem some people say melkisedek
was Jesus Christ no Christ has never me
the king the king of an Earthly city mzc
was the king of Salem and he was a
priest on the earth on the earth Jesus
never functioned as a priest he's
functioning now as a priest in heaven
interceding for us on the earth Christ
was a prophet the prophet of God the
mouthpiece of God not a priest he is a
priest now melchisedec was a priest and
he was a king Christ wasn't a king on
the earth and he wasn't a priest now in
Hebrews seven melkisedek is described as
having not mother father or mother or
beginning of life but made like under
the Son of God abideth the king priest
continually because we have no record of
melchisedec's ancestry some people
believe he was Jesus no the Bible uses
that as a symbol of the minist the
Priestly Ministry of Christ there are
three major offices Christ will occupy
Prophet priest and King now listen
carefully my friends are online listen
carefully Prophet Christ was a prophet
but his prophetic Ministry was based on
the prophetic Ministry of
Moses and so in Deuteronomy 18:15 the
Bible says a prophet will the Lord your
God raise up unto you from the midst of
you of your brethren like unto me Moses
said there'll be a prophet just like me
what made Moses different from any other
Prophet when Miriam and Aaron rebelled
against the authority of Moses in
numbers chap 12 God said in verse 6 if
there's a prophet among you I will make
myself known to him but he said my
servant Moses is not like that I will
speak to him mouth to mouth face to face
now the only other Prophet who had that
was Jesus Christ who was in the bosom of
the father and so Moses said a prophet
will be raised up just like me you must
listen to him in Acts 3:22 the Bible
says for Moses truly said unto the
fathers a prophet shall the god raise up
unto you he referring to Jesus Christ in
verse 26 now melchisedec then is the
Earthly symbol of the Priestly Ministry
sorry Moses is the Earthly symbol of the
prophetic Ministry of Christ so Christ
was a prophet based on Moses's Prophet
prophetic Ministry now I said Prophet I
said King in Acts chapter 2 when uh the
the angel Gabriel came not act chapter 2
Luke chapter 1 when the angel Gabriel
came to Mary that she'd have a child in
verse 31 the angel said and thou behold
thou shal conceive in thy womb and bring
forth a son and thou shalt call his name
Jesus he shall be great and shall be
called the son of the highest and the
Lord God shall give unto him the Throne
of his father David when Christ reigns
forever in the earth he' be sitting on
the throne of his father David which
means the kingship of David is the
Earthly symbol of the Eternal kingship
of Christ and his kingdom now but David
is dead Moses died and then was raised
up by God now the other office is priest
melchisedek now who was a priest in
Salem is the Earthly symbol of the
priesthood of Christ going on now but
look at the three offices Prophet Moses
King David priest
melkisedek when Christ sets up the new
world there will be no need for prophets
when he sets up the new world there'll
be no need for priest when he sets up
the new world he'll be a king
so if one of the three had to be alive
or had to represent Christ or was
actually Christ it would have to be
David because David represented a status
Christ will have forever but in the new
world we don't need prophets we don't
need priests but we'll have a king
melchisedec was a human being but his
priesthood merely symbolized the higher
priesthood of Christ as Moses as a
prophet his prophetic Ministry symbolize
the prophetic Ministry of Christ and
David's King his kingship symbolize the
Eternal kingship of Christ melkisedek
was a real person he was not Jesus
Christ sorry to take so long to answer
that question thank
you there's a question what should one
do to keep children from running in
church go to Exodus chapter 19 this is
an important question there seems to be
a belief among members that uh God
accepts irreverence from children and I
expect reverence from all the people
let's pray again before we go any fur
the father as we continue answering
questions give us the right words dear
God to Enlighten your people but more so
that you may be glorified in Jesus name
we pray amen amen God gives Moses
instructions to inform the Israelites
how to prepare for his coming he's
coming down to Mount Si to bring the law
now here's what he tells Moses to tell
the Israelites read verse 12 and verse
13 of Exodus 19 and Thou
shalt you shall set bounds for the
people all around bounds meaning limits
uhhuh saying take he to yourselves that
you do not go up to the mountain okay
pause don't go up to this mountain
that's where I'm coming down this is my
area don't go up keep reading don't go
up to the mountain nor touch it face M
what whoever touches the mountain shall
surely be put put to death God is saying
if anyone touches this mountain that I
have raised from have reserved for me
that person is dead now let's see how
far the death penalty went read verse 13
not a hand shall touch him but he shall
surely be stoned or shot with an arrow
now listen carefully whether it be
whether man or beast uh he shall not
leave now pause man or beast that
touches that is dead question now for
those of us who listening and we're
reasoning did that include children the
answer has to be yes yes if a child had
touched that mountain dead which means
the parents would have to monitor their
children because children being children
they wander around they run around they
have no thinking capacity as an adult
has they would have touched that
mountain and been struck dead by a holy
God who never does wrong so the parents
had to monitor their children and
monitor their animals because animals
also wander around God is a serious God
he requires reverence
and respect and the church is not a
playground but some cultures they almost
worship children so the children can do
anything they want the children run
around the church and people just sit
there and smile no no no no no this is a
church and the people ought to instruct
their
children children learn much more than
we think my good pastor they understand
more than we think when they are trained
they act according to their training and
if children are train at home to respect
the Church of God they will respect the
Church of God God is God no matter what
the age limit is and he must be
respected all parents listening to me
yes children are children I know that
but do all you can to monitor your
children in church the church is not a
playground that's where we got to
worship God and God demands
reverence and it appears to me from what
just say that part of it is training
ourselves learning what our beauty is
from scripture then we will be able to
know what is a responsibility of our
children absolutely thank you next one
is um how can someone know when the Holy
Spirit has come upon him or her
especially when the person has been
praying for that if a person is filled
with the Holy Spirit the person's
primary urge is to do whatever pleases
God and what pleases God is expressed in
Ecclesiastes 1213 let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter for God
and keep his Commandments for this is
the whole duty of man a person led by
the spirit of God has one overriding
urge to obey God and to produce through
that Spirit enabled obedience the fruits
of the spirit if the spirit of God is in
you your primary desire is to do what
pleases God and to obey him
thank
you in other words obedience is the only
reliable evidence of conversion and the
presence of the spirit obedience
obedience next one is are animals
required to obey God and if not why was
the serpent in Genesis 3 cursed no
animals are not required to obey the Ten
Commandments but keep in mind God place
all creation under Adam's Dominion so
when Adam sinned he sin affected the
entire creation you see now the serpent
was cursed by God yes the serpent is
part of
creation whatever God does is right
that's a fundamental principle even if
we don't understand whatever God does is
Right Psalm 145:1 17 the Lord is
righteous in all his ways and holy in
all his words he cannot do wrong so if I
with my limited intellect cannot
understand what God does it does not
make God wrong nor is God obligated to
explain everything to me in detail when
Adam sin the entire creation came under
the curse of God and that of course
included the serpent animals you know I
love going to Parks
safaris but let me tell you something
life in National Parks is frightening
animals killing each other lions hunting
gazelle crocodiles catching those
crossing the river you know scorpions
stinging everywhere you go something is
killing something why is that the curse
of sin how did that come about Adam the
supervisor of creation he sinned and the
curse of sin the rebelliousness that
Adam developed as a result of sin it
passed to the Animal Kingdom but animals
are not required to obey the Ten
Commandments but animals obey God God
commanded Ravens to feed
Elijah uh First Kings 617 God can
command Locust to Devour the land 2
Chronicles 7:13 he can do that he can
command the clouds not to drop the rain
Isaiah
5:6 they obey him but they're not called
upon to obey the Ten Commandments those
are moral Commandments they are reserved
for intelligent beings human beings and
angels all right thank
you does Colossians 2:16 say that we
shouldn't keep the Sabbath and shouldn't
observe dietary laws and related to that
is Romans 14:14 mhm the question being
does do these verses mean that somebody
can eat anything let's go to Colossians
2: 16 a very very common verse used by
people who uh try to show the Sabbath
need not be kept but that's not what the
Bible is saying let us go Romans chapter
Colossians sorry chapter 2 verse 16 and
the person says does that mean we don't
have to keep the Sabbath let them
therefore judge you in let no one judge
you in food or in drink or
regarding a festival or a new moon or
sabbaths all right the Bible doesn't say
the ver does say don't keep it it said
don't let anyone judge you that is not a
statement prohibiting the observance of
the Sabbath but read verse 17
now which are a shadow of things to come
ah you that the word Shadow connects all
of that to the sanctuary system the
entire Sanctuary system was a shadow of
things to come and so we read in 1
Corinthians 5:7 Christ Our Passover is
crucified for us the sac the Passover
sacrifice was a shadow of something to
come and the Fulfillment was Calvary
when the ultimate Passover was
sacrificed all the sacrificial
activities and and sacrifices and
rituals there were a shadow the entire
Century itself was a shadow of the
original in heaven now a shadow of
things to come the Sabbath is not a
shadow of things to come the Sabbath is
a memorial of something past which is
creation not a shadow of something to
come now go to First Corinthians 7 read
verse 19 let me show you what the same
Paul says because it's Paul in
Colossians 21:16 who says let no man
judge you in observance of a holy day
listen to what the same Paul says in 1
Corinthians
7:19 7:19 he says circumcision is
nothing and uncircumcision is nothing
but keep the Comm and that includes the
seventh day Sabbath what matters so the
same Paul says what really matters is
not being circumcised or now when Paul
said that keep in mind to whom he's
writing the Jews were so fixed on
circumcision the word was used to refer
to them they were called the
circumcision because it was such a
central part of their lives and to have
Paul say circumcision is nothing is to
have Paul say your culture is
nothing you know it's like telling the
Messi in East Africa cows are nothing
you know you can't do that but Paul says
circumcision is nothing uncircumcision
is nothing what really counts is keeping
the Comm he said he didn't say keeping
nine he said keeping the commandments so
that Paul in 1 Corinthians 7:19 cannot
reverse his words in Colossians 21:16
Colossians 2:16 does not forbid the
keeping of the Sabbath it says don't let
prisons judge you but keep in mind there
are several
ceremonial sabbaths in the Bible they're
all listed in Leviticus 23 and they all
are attached to the seven annual Feast
we have Passover number one Feast of 11
bread Feast of first fruit Feast of
Weeks day of trumpet day of atonement
Feast of Tabernacles in that order
spring festivals fall festivals they all
teach us about salvation from the time
you accept Christ to when you enter the
kingdom Colossians 21:16 does not forbid
the observance of the Sabbath day
because Paul tells us clearly what
really comes with God is to live
according to his
Commandments okay and R Romans 14:14
okay let's go to that Romans 1414 14
listen to the same Paul Paul writes to
say I know that I'm convicted I'm
convinced by the Lord Jesus that there
is nothing unclean in itself right pause
there's not there's nothing unclean in
itself about a pig because God made pigs
there's nothing unclean in itself about
a dog God made dogs there's nothing
unclean in itself about a lion God made
L but when it comes to diet those
animals are not fit for food in that
sense they're inclean are you with me
but God never deliberately makes an
unclean thing because the Bible tells us
in Genesis 1: 131 and God saw everything
that he had made including pigs lion
snakes and he saw that it was very good
so we must reason when with respect to
diet don't eat a snake with respect to
diet don't eat a slug you see but God
made these things to fulfill their
functions in nature but when you take
them out of their function and have them
function as a dietary item that's where
you get into trouble they were not made
to be actually none of the animals were
made to be eaten let me be frank before
sin none after sin God restrict us now
you may eat these but not those
and we have unclean animals going all
the way back to um Genesis 7 when the
animals went into the ark Genesis 7
verse 2 and three clean and clean clean
and clean way back before there were any
Israelites and so any animal is not good
for food some people think that's what
the verse is saying M no animal is
unclean in and of itself it is the youth
to which we put that animal that
introduces uncleanness and when used for
food even though it's banned by God
that's where uncleanness becomes a
reality all right next one we have what
is solar SC scripture solar scriptura is
an expression used by the reformers in
the days of Martin Luther and
mington it simply means the Bible only
the Bible and the Bible only that's the
principle Martin Luther and reformers
used to challenge the Catholic teaching
that justification by faith is not by
faith alone but by faith and partially
your own Works Martin Luther Said No by
faith alone and this is based on the
Bible the Bible alone the Catholic
Church uses tradition plus the Bible
they said no solar scriptura the Bible
and the Bible alone that's what solar
scriptura mean then there solar feed by
faith alone they had about five of these
saying but solar scriptural simply means
the Bible and the Bible alone Al MH
thank you how can I be a missionary in a
new country for instance an an Islamic
country an Islamic country all right
everyone on the face of the earth needs
to hear the gospel whether Islamic
country Buddhist country whatever
confusion this
country you have to be sure this is
God's will for you never go where God
didn't send you it may look like a good
idea let me go to some Islamic country
and preach Jesus Christ fine it may look
like a good idea God may not want you
there's Peter there's Paul God sent
Peter to the Jews he sent Paul to the
Gentiles you see he he he he prepared
them and made them suited for different
groups of people so God may not want you
so make sure you seeking God's will you
want to go to Islamic country what are
you doing right where you are to develop
the skills what are you doing in your
neighborhood in your church in your town
in your city in your village to spread
the gospel are you practicing the skills
of evangelism where you are before you
go off into strange environment where
people know nothing about Christ and try
to preach Christ remember you shall be
Witnesses unto me both in Jerusalem and
Judea and Samaria the uttermost parts of
the earth so start at home do what you
can show God what you're willing to do
then God may move you to some area where
you desire to go and there is this
period where Paul I believe in act 16
where he wants to go to a given place
for Mission and God says you can't go
there the spirit said yes God said no
and that's the need for us to surrender
our plans to him and ask him to guide us
even if the plan looks good David wanted
to build the temple for God excellent
idea God said no not you let Solomon do
it so the fact it's a good idea does not
mean God wants you to do it he may want
someone else to do it all right thank
you how can I memorize the Bible and for
those who speak more than one language
which language would do you recommend
how can one memorize the Bible there's
one fundamental principle constant
repetition over and over and
over what book do I recommend for uh did
you say book or language language oh the
language in which you're strongest yeah
for those who speak more than one yeah
well the your most basic language if
it's English use English if it's French
use French the one in which you're
strongest and most uh skillful use that
language but the principle for
memorization the most fundamental
principle is constant repe when you're
brushing your teeth recite when you're
taking a shower recite when you're
driving recite when you're whatever
waiting in line in the bank a Que recite
all the time occupy your mind with the
word of God and the more you do it the
better it becomes and one my favorite
writer says that which at first seems
Difficult by constant repetition grows
easy and that's absolutely true constant
repetition ask God to help you because
God wants you to memorize Psalm 119
verse1 Thy word have I hi in my heart
that I might not sin against thee God
wants that word hidden in your mind so
you have it under all situations and at
all occasions but con now of course you
can write on uh 3x five cards you can
sing it singing is one excellent way to
memorize the Bible I don't do it that
way but God deals with us differently
writing it out then you interact
physically with the word visually you
look at it you may listen to recording
then that's auditory then you write it
that kinesthetic so you have visual
auditory kinesthetic the more senses you
bring the more effectively you anchor
the word of God in your mind I'm very
delighted with that person who want
wants to memorize God's word I urge all
of you listening make an effort and
because I'm very biased I recommend the
King James version all right and may I
add that have the right motive to have
the right don't do it to show off don't
do that do it to glorify God and to have
a source of spiritual power amen thank
you I mean don't just memorize it obey
it mhm this is not a poem by Shakespeare
this is the Living Word of God obey it
memorize it obey it and use it to
encourage someone else amen all right
how do I make things that require
discipline for instance Bible study
don't feel not to feel like a
chore it depends on how important that
thing is to
you people say to me all the time how do
you don't you get tired of traveling and
flying and I said no because I'm doing
what I love to do when you love to do
something is not aure it is simply self
expression so when I stand In a Pulpit
I'm just expressing myself when I'm on a
plane going to some distant part of the
world to preach for God this is just who
I am and so if you have a responsibility
to take care of if it's important to you
it will not be a CH so you have to
connect it to is this God's will for me
how will this glorify God everything we
do must come down to the glory of God
whether therefore you eat or drink or
whatsoever you do 1 Corinthians 10:31 do
all to the glory of God Is This For the
Glory of God if it is and your life is
surrendered to God it becomes a task of
delight not a CH when the disciples were
beaten Peter and John for preaching
Christ in Acts chapter 4 they left
rejoicing that they were counted worthy
to suffer for the cause of Christ they
left rejoicing they' been
whipped because the motivation was
different and so whatever responsibility
you have discipline tells you get to it
but the motivation must be the glory of
God first and
foremost okay thank you by the way a
Christian must be a disciplined
person if you ask to sing special music
rehearse practice don't just jump up and
say God understand don't be ill
disciplined rehearse practice we must be
disciplined people and a disciplined
person accomplishes much more than one
who is not disciplined even though that
person may be a genius but not
disciplined that person cannot fulfill
his or her potential okay thank
you are children born out of wedlock
cursed and uh can such children claim
the promise given to Jeremiah in
Jeremiah 1 I believe verse 5 verse 5 yes
a child born out of wedlock is not a sin
wish I can say that in all the languages
on the face of the earth a child is is
not a sin fornication is a sin adultery
is a sin homosexuality is a sin
lesbianism is a sin bestiality is a sin
a child in a woman's womb is not a sin
that has made very clear people ask me
sometime can I dedicate should we
dedicate a child born out of wedlock yes
that child is given Life by God God
could have cut life off in the womb but
he didn't he allowed that child to live
so a child is not a sin and if you're in
that condition and I speak respectfully
the child you're carrying is not a sin
if you confess your sin to God God
forgives and he forgets commit that
child to God raise that child for the
glory of God now can the child benefit
from Jeremiah 15 if Jeremiah 15 says
before I formed you in the belly I knew
you and before th came is form out of
the womb I sanctify thee and I ordain
the prophet unto the Nations yes if God
gives you life he allows you to live he
will give you a
purpose God never gives life
aimlessly if he allows you to live he's
given you life he attaches a purpose the
way you came into existence may not have
been his way but since he allowed you to
live and I have to keep saying that he
allowed you to live he will give you a
purpose MH and so please a baby in a
mother's womb is not a sin
makes me think of Ishmael and God says
I'll bless him he wasn't part of my plan
that's right but I'm going to make him a
great na y very good very thank you okay
all right how should Seventh Day
Adventist parents and also by extension
the church deal with those who have
special needs the greatest special need
is the need the sinner has for Jesus
Christ and God put everything in place a
church is a place where people are
unselfish in their Devotion to another
if there's one member with a special
need the whole church must be concerned
you simply can't say that's his business
M the whole CH you see Paul compares the
church to a human body they the toes
they the fingers whatever clearly the
brain and the heart are the most
important you can lose a finger and
you're fine but Paul says if a little
member suffers the whole body must
suffer if you shoot me in my finger
you've shot me you haven't simply shot
my finger you have shot me me if someone
came to me which of your fingers would
you like me to cut off none which of
your toes none which of your toenails
would you love me to pull out with app
pliers none and so if one member of the
church is suffering the whole church
must come together to ease that person
suffering because the whole church must
suffer with that person we have many
churches where there members who are
suffering and members don't care or
didn't notice or not aware if one one
member suffers the whole church must
suffer in other words if one member has
a special need the entire church comes
together to provide that need for that
person okay that's love in the church
and that's a church can't solve every
problem but the church will make its
best effort yeah because Christ values
that
person yeah and that's what exactly
Jesus did while he was on the face of
the Earth he saw the needy and reached
out to them responded mhm mhm mhm
all right and is it true that you can't
stop sinning and as long as you are
living in the sinful world that's
absolutely not true that's a doctrine of
the devil there's no such thing as you
cannot stop sinning now you cannot stop
the devil from tempting you but you can
decide I will not offend God Daniel
decided I will not pray to a man I
prefer to be eaten by lions the three
Hebrew boys decided we prefer to burn a
li than bow to an image there are people
in the Bible who've chosen death rather
than sin against God and so you can stop
sinning by the power of God yes that's
God's desire now unto him that is able
to keep you from falling you see and the
power of Christ is able to do that but
it must be our great desire our great
desire it does not happen automatically
we must fight the good fight of Faith
daily first uh Timothy 6: 12 fight the
good fight of faith it does not happen
automatically Galatians 5:17 the flesh
lusteth against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh but the battle
is
winnable the battle is winnable constant
surrender of to life to God staying in
the word of God Thy word have I hi in my
heart that I might not sin against thee
uh Psalm 119 verse uh 11 verse 9 where
with all shall a young man cleanse his
ways never get rid of sin by taking he
there according to Thy word John 15:3
Jesus told the disciples now you clean
through the word clean from what sin
which I have spoken unto you Jesus
prayed in John 17:1 15 I pray not that
thou shallal take them out of the world
but that thou sh keep them from the evil
can God keep us from the evil Jesus
prayed and told the father do that then
he tells the father how to do it verse
17 sanctify them through thy truth Thy
word is truth we can come to the place
where we no longer sin not we cannot sin
we choose not to sin by the grace and
power of God abiding grace of God and
that Grace is administered through the
word and the spirit in other words if we
think we can't stop sinning we're
limiting the power of God in our lives
yes we're telling God you don't have the
power M all
right coming to the next one is did
Lucifer rebel against God before or
after the creation of the human race if
you use the biblical evidence we look at
the chronology of creation the tree of
the knowledge of Good and Evil was made
on the third day
okay Adam was made on the sixth if the
tree of the knowledge of Good and Evil
was made on the third day sin existed
before Adam was
made on the basis of that alone we see
there's the presence of sin in the
universe before Adam was made and so yes
Lucifer rebelled before the world was
created M all right thank you should I
repent after I have heard a bad dream
okay I don't have a commandment for that
what I do know here's what I do and I'm
not setting myself up as an example we
must never think we're too
good never think I don't need to
confess if I dream and I sin in my dream
as soon as I wake up I confess that sin
because it tells me that thing I dreamed
is something I could easily do you you
follow me and so while I don't have a
Bible verse I recommend as a servant of
God if you sinned in your dream you lose
Nothing by saying father I am sorry
because this shows me what I'm capable
of
doing you lose nothing never come to the
place where you think I don't have to
confess don't ever come to that point
yeah and it could also be a moment for
you to say God is there sin in me search
my heart and yes there be
any remove it Psalm 139: 23- 24 search
me oh God what is there in my mind
during the day that produced that dream
yeah mhm thank you and um we have one
more uh is there a Bible verse that
shows that Cain knew he was supposed to
offer an animal for a sacrifice and
chose not to okay here's where we have
to reason together did Cain know what
God wanted now God does not execute
judgment on someone who's ignorant let's
go to John 15 mhm read John 15 let's
read verse 22 and verse 23 of verse 24
hear what Jesus tells uh his disciples
John 15 verse 22 and verse 24 John 15
22 if I had not come and spoken to them
right they had not had sin would not
they would have no sin that's right in
other words they had no
knowledge where knowledge is absent God
does not charge a person with sin even
though the person does something wrong
the person is not charged but we know
that Cain was condemned by God so Cain
had to have known read verse 24 24 reads
if I had not done among them The Works
which Noone other man did they would
have no sin in other words I spoke to
them I did Works they had evidence from
me consequently their Works amounted to
sin go to John chapter
9 let's read verse
41 read
39-41 then and Jesus said for judgment I
have come into this world that those who
do not see who do not see may see and
that those who see may be made blind yes
now listen to the Pharisees and the Jews
then some of the Pharisees who were with
him who who heard um who were with him
heard these words and said to him are we
blind also listen to Jesus now and Jesus
said to them if you blind you would have
no sin but now you say we see know
Therefore your sinth your sin remains
Cain was charged with sin because he
knew that's a principle of God you see
God does not execute judgment where
someone is ignorant in the days of your
ignorance he Winks he Winks acts
17:30 yeah he Winks in the time of
ignorance he could not wink at Cain Cain
knew clearly taught by his father Adam
what he should have brought and he
didn't that's why God said look do
what's right God can't say do what's
right without telling you he said if you
do what's right I'll receive you that's
what he said to him in Genesis chter 4
verse verse 6 if you do what's right and
so he he knew and God had to pass
judgment on him M God does God is such a
nice person he does not hold you guilty
in times of ignorance but God does not
glorify ignorance he wants people to
know the verse we use Act 17:30 in the
time of this ignorance God winked at but
now commandeth men everywhere to repent
he wants you to know because ignorance
has no v no
benefits all right and uh that brings us
to the close of our first
session pray as we close Okay Okay Our
Father in heaven we thank you for
calling us to do a work Angels would
love to do if we fell short forgive us
father help us to do better the next
time I pray you'd bless those who listen
father
grant them the humility of Jesus Christ
to accept thus say the Lord and to guide
their lives by Your Word put a double
blessing on their children I pray in the
name of Jesus Christ amen amen